I’ve got an attitude of gratitude!
Cuz who wouldn’t working on a cool internet
show like DNews?
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for what will
be my last episode as an official DNews host.
It’s been a great couple of years.
This morning I was sitting in our meeting,
thinking about how grateful I am for our audience
and my team….and how grateful I am for gratitude,
actually.
Gratitude is a super important thing for human
beings - it goes beyond just being polite.
Robert Emmons, a gratitude expert, argues
that gratitude is an affirmation of goodness.
It affirms that there are good things in the
world, and a lot of the time, it’s other
PEOPLE that fill our lives with goodness.
This manifests in the scientific studies of
gratitude over and over again.
We see a strong link between people who take
time to think about who and what they’re
grateful for and the experience of emotional
well-being.
Couples who take time to show gratitude to
each other experience higher levels of relationship
satisfaction and quality the next day.
Grateful people sleep better and they’re
more resilient in times of struggle.
Gratitude also changes the way we treat each
other.
It makes us more willing to forgive and to
treat others with kindness.
In one study in the journal Social Psychological
and Personality Science, participants who
were primed by thinking about things they’re
grateful for were half as likely to assign
other participants undesirable tasks.
Why is gratitude so great?
Well...everyone needs to feel like they’re
valuable and competent, and we all need to
feel connected to others in some way.
When you say thank you to someone, those people
report much higher levels of both their perceived
competence and their value to others.
It’s really powerful!
The problem for me is, a lot of the time I’ll
FEEL grateful but forget to EXPRESS that gratitude.
And it’s the expression that has the most
impact.
So, in my departure from DNews, I wanted to
say thank you to all of you who have supported
me and the growth of DNews.
Thank you for your kind tweets, for sharing
our videos, for your follows and likes and
interesting comments.
We do notice, and it means a lot to us.
I’m also so so grateful for the intelligent
and talented team here at DNews: Trace, Tara,
Pam, Chastity, Jared, Barry - thank you all
for making this such an awesome adventure.
For the rest of you out there, I’ll be around
on the interwebs.
If you want to follow my work after DNews,
you can find my personal channel at youtube.com/lacigreen
- and of course, the crew on this channel
will continue to make more interesting science
updates for you.
Thanks again everyone, truly.
Over n out.